- [Instructor] What we're
going to do in this video
is use the online graphing
calculator Desmos,
and explore the relationship
between vertical
and horizontal asymptotes, and think about
how they relate to what we know
about limits.
So let's first graph two over x minus one,
so let me get that one graphed,
and so you can immediately
see that something interesting
happens at x is equal to one.
If you were to just
substitute x equals one
into this expression, you're going to get
two over zero, and whenever
you get a non-zero thing,
over zero, that's a
good sign that you might
be dealing with a vertical asymptote.
In fact we can draw
that vertical asymptote
right over here at x equals one.
But let's think about how
that relates to limits.
What if we were to explore
the limit as x approaches one
of f of x is equal to
two over x minus one,
and we could think about it from the left
and from the right, so if we approach one
from the left, let me zoom in a little bit
over here, so we can see as
we approach from the left
when x is equal to zero, the f of x
would be equal to negative two,
when x is equal to point five, f of x
is equal to negative of
four, and then it just gets
more and more negative the closer we get
to one from the left.
I could really, so I'm
not even that close yet
if I get to let's say 0.91,
I'm still nine hundredths
less than one, I'm at
negative 22.222, already.
And so the limit as we
approach one from the left
is unbounded, some people would say
it goes to negative
infinity, but it's really
an undefined limit, it is unbounded
in the negative direction.
And likewise, as we
approach from the right,
we get unbounded in the
positive infinity direction
and technically we would
say that that limit
does not exist.
And this would be the
case when we're dealing
with a vertical asymptote
like we see over here.
Now let's compare that
to a horizontal asymptote
where it turns out that the limit
actually can exist.
So let me delete these or
just erase them for now,
and so let's look at this function
which is a pretty neat
function, I made it up
right before this video started
but it's kind of cool
looking, but let's think
about the behavior as
x approaches infinity.
So as x approaches infinity,
it looks like our y value
or the value of the
expression, if we said y
is equal to that expression, it looks like
it's getting closer and
closer and closer to three.
And so we could say that we
have a horizontal asymptote
at y is equal to three, and we could also
and there's a more rigorous
way of defining it,
say that our limit as
x approaches infinity
is equal of the expression
or of the function,
is equal to three.
Notice my mouse is
covering it a little bit
as we get larger and larger, we're getting
closer and closer to three,
in fact we're getting
so close now, well here
you can see we're
getting closer and closer
and closer to three.
And you could also
think about what happens
as x approaches negative infinity and here
you're getting closer
and closer and closer
to three from below.
Now one thing that's
interesting about horizontal
asymptotes is you might
see that the function
actually can cross a horizontal asymptote.
It's crossing this horizontal asymptote
in this area in between and
even as we approach infinity
or negative infinity, you can oscillate
around that horizontal asymptote.
Let me set this up, let me
multiply this times sine of x.
And so there you have it,
we are now oscillating
around the horizontal asymptote,
and once again this limit can exist
even though we keep crossing
the horizontal asymptote,
we're getting closer and
closer and closer to it
the larger x gets.
And that's actually the
key difference between
a horizontal and a vertical asymptote.
Vertical asymptotes if you're
dealing with a function,
you're not going to cross
it, while with a horizontal
asymptote, you could,
and you are just getting
closer and closer and closer to it
as x goes to positive infinity or as x
goes to negative infinity.